like I mentioned before blown-down was a
guy who grew up Catholic he grew up in
Dijon France it's fairly typical
formation bright kid and he saw the
direction that his society had gone
we've become very very secular very very
deliberately anti-catholic comments were
being excluded from politics from
intellectual life and he thought that
part of his hauling his location he
actually writes about this way was to
work with in philosophy to show that
philosophy can now truly be itself
cannot truly be philosophical to the
extent that it has to be cannot realize
what it's made to be without engaging
theology without engaging Christianity
so a lot of people wrote his works on
guys what we call apologetics which is
sort of a reason defensive the ideas you
begin from the starting point of a leaf
and then he never really you know
question that belief you just sort of
try to provide a bunch of reasons for it
glowing dome was an extra doing and he
is I would say he is one of the great
philosophers of the 20th century he's
very underrated he is ed was at least as
profound as Heidegger and within
theological circles that's much in
Protestant circles but of Catholic
circles
he is as important as any other
philosophers because his thought
actually led to Vatican 2 through two
different currents the influence isn't
what are called the transcendental
Thomas so Joseph Marshall first who
influences Karl Rahner one of the great
20th century theologians and rahner is
one of the Rana and Iran Aryans are one
of the main groups at Vatican too he
also influences off all the people that
are known as a resource for our new girl
tlg people so I made aloo bag is the
mall whole bunch of different people are
influenced by him and because what we're
studying lonedell probably you could say
pulled off what it was that he thought
Christian philosophers so I'm going to
give used a few traits the the materials
that i sent to dr. English to send out
to you are mostly excerpts from bone
death and they talked about a lot of
interesting ideas I'm just going to hit
out a few of them but I'm starting with
this critical side lonedell says that
there's there's two errors that would
block the way to truly Christian
possible in part because they would make
philosophy no longer what it ought to be
they would debase it see philosophy like
any other discipline has its own set of
norms its own goals and one of the goals
that is always motivated philosophers is
to think things out to the very basis
not to not to remain content with
unquestioned assumptions to actually
there's a reality out there you want to
know it doesn't make somebody a
philosopher not the fact that they have
a PhD in philosophy or
you know call themselves a philosopher
anything with that would really make
somebody a philosopher according to
somebody like Vogue Elle is this desire
to know and there he is you know you
saying same things that other people
like Aristotle Hagel has said in their
time Aristotle says all net by desire by
nature desire to know philosopher just
ends up doing it more apparently so
philosophy is also going to develop over
time to them because if you really
really do desire to know if you really
want to understand things you're going
to engage with what's out there so you
know let's think back a little bit to
say Thomas Aquinas assume you guys are
all familiar with with him what how do
we usually characterized him he was this
great medieval thinker what made him
great other than the fact that he's in
their history was people talk about why
was he
throughout big books that's not about to
make great coffee table books are big
books we don't say that they're often
right so why does this guy I find us
great loss
okay it's a good way of thinking about
it he applied reason to me if you
actually read through of you see them
sometimes you might have fed up with
them because you might be waiting for
here's the end here is a conclusion and
then you'll say well here's what I think
after a lot of thinking about it but
let's think about it some more yeah yeah
and why does he do that well because
that's that's a reason leads them to to
not be contempt with let's say okay got
the solution not even go home that's
coming out of lock love for knowledge
what else does he do though that's that
makes them important historically yeah
sort of clarifies relationships and also
the Christian God yeah here Europe
Ronald Aristotle and Claire minds of
their so very good he is the first
person to thoroughly work through
Arizona his teacher Albert the Great is
doing so other people are doing so the
Thomas goes as far as you can into a
crisis T as a thinker who believes and
who is gone you know actually practicing
Dominican friar who is saying the
Liturgy of the hours daily got very
active prayer life was living in
comedies is you know living as a
Christian he wants to know can this guy
was pagan Aristotle can he actually have
anything of value and in order to know
whether he has anything of value you've
got actually go to the ground you can't
just say I'm going to read a few books
he wants to read everything there so he
not only reads Aristotle he rates
commentaries on their stop and he
distinguishes where he says well
aerosols right about this wrong about
this and he often uses Aristotle against
Aristotle to do so that's part what
makes him great what is he doing there
he's engaging with the thought available
at his time so Thomas our coins were
around today would he stop with Arizona
what do you think
I her style that's good enough don't
need to read anything more who would he
have read would be on his bookshelf I'm
very worn out via manual can't maybe
yeah and actually the really fertile
Thomas we're doing just this they would
bring Thomas's thought and dialogue with
cod with hable with philosophers today
somebody was a good example that is
Alistair McIntyre Notre Dame still
plugging away after 80 years he's still
pushing hard as at Ole Miss engaging
modern thought so blown Delta wanted to
do something similar he thought the
philosophy it couldn't stop with Thomas
she'll so no more exam were stopping
with tunnels way stopping with Arizona
they said the others Christian
philosophy happened in the Middle Ages
we should mainly do that sort of thing
now lonedell thought no you know
modernity we've thought a lot of new
things out we've discovered new things
we have to take account of that we have
to do what Thomas did go to the ground
make it through completely and then we
can see whether philosophy really does
in Christianity we could see whether
human intellectual life needs christian
because maybe a dozen maybe the
rationalist are right maybe that was
fine for the age of faith the Middle
Ages but we don't actually need it now
we won't know that until we actually
think it all the way through so that's
what he did he thought that there were
two things that were standing in the way
of Christian philosophy one was what he
called conceptions and this he talks
about is the idea that philosophy and
with concepts clear concepts and so all
you have to do is come up with some nice
definitions and now you can reason from
they can be as complex as you want but
you're ultimately going to decide things
in a sort of verbal let's say we begin
from this definition faith and reason
are two separate things they begin from
different starting points therefore
faith and reason can makes the way a lot
of people reason isn't it is that good
philosophy will doubtless they know
because you're beginning from a bunch of
assumptions using those concepts and
then reasoning uncritically using those
concepts there are a lot of dogmas that
are built into our culture like that
that wound l would say these are
beginning from unquestioned starting so
if you do that that's not going to work
for you so let's say you have an open
philosophy he talks about the need for
philosophy to open up within itself as a
beautiful metaphor philosophy has to
open it open up within itself an empty
space where I can actually welcome the
supernatural the supernatural and the
determinate of the Christian sense
meaning what the supernatural order got
revelation
the infused virtues all these sorts of
things that make up Christian life
philosophy can't just accept that stuff
from Christianity
by itself philosophy s they actually
open up within itself a space for them
see if the revelation or doctrine or
ideas or just coming down from on high
from Christianity and then the
philosopher is just supposed to take
account of them that means that
philosophy becomes no longer autonomous
which means that it's no longer really
philosophical because now it's through
unquestioningly accepting things and
that's not good philosophy so quick
philosophy could it do this what's up
good philosophy open up ground within
itself for accepting something higher
than well this is what blown doubt did
in his work and if you read his book box
which is available in English
translation you will find him doing
precisely with us what he does if he
starts with the lowest levels of human
action when he builds all the way up and
he wants to see quit human beings quit
human reason by itself suffice on to
itself could that be all there is and
what do you do you actually have to do
the experiment you have to see whether
everything could be explicable if you
take out of 10 Christianity have the
picture take everything that comes from
Christianity out of the picture and what
do you find if you do this in an
open-minded way and you don't already
you know skew the game by making
assumptions that rule it up you find no
as a matter of fact philosophy opens up
all sorts of problems that I can't solve
this might be something of a turning off
and floss people go into philosophy
classes and sometimes they come out more
is that when they came in that maybe
philosophy doing its job right
philosophy should open up problems that
the philosopher by himself or herself
can't solve then they have to turn
somewhere else where can they turn maybe
other philosophers yeah but that's not
going to fix the problem visit where
else could their turn they could you
know what let's think about this is sort
of in a higher and lower perspective if
if you're living the philosophical life
and you're really thinking things out
and you're spending time motivated by
this web of knowledge and you're
encountering difficulties that you can't
quite make sense of and you're thinking
the great philosophical faulty what's
the meaning of history what's the
meeting at human life what what types of
life are better than than others what is
the good and you're not able to fully
figure these things out what am i what
am I supposed to do what are your
alternatives let's say you're going to
you're going to you're not going to find
your answers and philosophy you're not
just going to throw away philosophy how
much you go lower what might you looked
what activities would be
wait get you out of the problem